ça arrive recrute ses pommes
de 9h30
[Musique]
il doit faire pour refaire dans les
comics mèche blanche
[Musique]
maintenant si c'est une vraie ou si
c'est une fausse c'est que moi je
devrais la soufflante les genres ici tu
vas voir
et quand j'ai lu le livre de mona
chollet sorcière dedans elle expliqué
que que les coupes dans les choses se
resserrent les gens qu'il chassait les
horaires et rasé la tête des sancerre à
la recherche de la tâche de la sorcière
qui est un peu un mythe est en fait ya
beaucoup de femmes qui se sont fait
exécuter
parce que j'avais justement des taches
blanches de vitiligo sur les crânes
exactement comme moi et que du coup elle
avait des mèches de cheveux blancs ou
d'été décoloration quand j'ai lu ça ça
me fait halluciner ce que je me suis du
genre c'est trop bizarre j'ai toujours
été un peu attiré par les sorcières et
de cette espèce de grosse mèche blanche
de cheveux et donc j'ai dit vas-y je
fais un steinmetz et je fais la moitié
ma frange en blanc disait c'est drôle
parce que d'habitude quand je viens à
lyon je viens à lyon pour me reposer un
peu tu vois pour chez pour être avec ma
famille pour way pour un peu prendre du
recul et tout parce que à paris j'ai
toujours un milliard de trucs à faire
est là du coup c'est la première fois où
je viens à lyon et au jeu fait aussi la
promotion c'est un concert et tout est
donc ça mélange tout un tas de trucs
donc une espèce de de vibe que je
connais pas trop mais qui est cool et
c'est vrai que je crois que c'est le
plus gros concert que je fais a lyon
c'est la plus grosse salle que je fais
jamais fait nos ces gros salsa d'autres
700 personnes je pense que moi c'est
gros sur les traces de mes racines à mon
école primaire
j'y suis pas retourné depuis depuis
longtemps je passe tout le temps devant
mais je suis pas rentré j'ai
l'impression que les espaces vont
paraître tout petit parce que ça me
paraissait immense à l'époque
ah ouais ouais ouais ouais non ça c'est
dingue ça va changer elle est où la
fameuse photo de deux classes classe de
cp en fait j'écrivais des poèmes
j'écrivais des histoires je me souviens
de lire des histoires ou des poèmes que
j'écrivais à ma classe dans cette dans
cette école là genre en cours de
français de dire voilà j'ai écrit une
nouvelle tout un des trucs très triste
ça n'a pas changé et et ouais je voulais
je savais pas si je voulais le chanteuse
mais en tout cas j'écrivais des choses
et je voulais je voulais way soit être
écrivait ne soit soit faire de l'amuser
que souhaite actrice sur un métier qui
est qui qui qui incluait de la roue de
la création quoi alors on vient
d'arriver à la salle de concert donc je
vais aller manger mais substanter pour
ensuite faire ma balance
suivez-moi les amis
[Musique]
moi c'est petit c'est que tim est grand
tout premier concert que j'avais c'était
dans des bars j'avais 15 16 ans à lyon
ensuite j'étais beaucoup de premières
parties
donc j'avais ma loge j'avais mon espace
j'avais ce type de salle mais en
première partie c'est pas du tout pareil
c'est genre tu arrivé un peu tu es le
dernier était la dernière priorité des
gens quant à la dernière préoccupation
du coup c'est assez cool de revenir dans
ses salades
toute mon équipe même si on est une
petite équipe pour l'instant on est sept
mais pour moi c'est beaucoup pour avoir
tourné pour leur vie
seul cet énorme c'est cette fois plus
hier j'ai joué un petit showcase à la
fnac et malheureusement tout le monde
n'a pas pu rentrer ce qui est déjà aussi
assez bizarre pour moi qui ai fait des
concerts devant beaucoup effet les
concerts devant peu de gens et et on n'a
pas pu rentrer et il ya des gens qui me
parlent dans la rue et tout et c'est
vrai que c'est complètement nouveau pour
moi et comme j'ai passé huit ans à faire
de la musique mon métier mais sans avoir
cet aspect là c'est tout nouveau
[Musique]
oui
footing d'avant concert avant chaque
concert et demi heure de footing
non c'est pas vrai malheureusement je me
suis habillé je me prépare une heure
avant le concert
même si j'ai pas du tout besoin d'une
heure et que et que j'aime bien être
pendant une heure non mais dans ma tenue
pour m'habituer à ma tenue ce que c'est
pas forcément détenus que je mets au
quotidien toi ça par exemple je ne mets
pas dans la rue j'ai un peu c'est un peu
plus stressé que d'habitude par le fait
que et mes parents ma prom à prendre ma
prof de chant de quand j'avais 8 ans qui
m'a fait découvrir barbara plein de gens
comme ça qu'ils m'ont pas vu depuis
super longtemps et qui n'ont jamais vu
bah la scénographie et le spectacle
comme elle est là qui est je pense le
plus abouti que j'ai fait et et en même
temps j'ai super hâte parce que parce
que je chantais pour des gens que je
connais c'est au staff ça donne du sens
aussi un peu au truc pas je fais
toujours un peu des jeux des
échauffements propos parce que je me
suis rendu compte que avant je ne
faisais pas et et quand tu fais quatre
concerts d'affilée et que tu fais pas
d'échauffement beaucoup dans ta voix se
casse
j'écoute une playlist des années 2000
hocine j'écoute kyo à laurie et j'écoute
vraiment les barreaux à tous les
classiques des années 2000 2010
[Musique]
en général on danse mais la personne par
mois avant que serge et des jeunes à
toute l'énergie positive que je que je
peux pas d'aller sur un concert concert
j'ai la main en-avant mauvaise troupe
on va faire le concert dans cinq minutes
mais un soutien en plastique en
plastique 4k l'emploi
on voudrait tout sourire bonsoir c'est
pas ce soir pour vos services devient
bon
trois minutes voyaient trois minutes je
serai seul alain coup ça montrant
minutes avant le concert mais ça monte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
lien
cette fois vous cette fois